hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast metabolites germs and
people eavesdropping on human microbial
communities it is presented by Katrine
white s'en PhD assistant professor of
molecular biology and biochemistry and
pediatrics at the University of
California Irvine I am Judy O'Rourke of
lab roots and I will be your moderator
for today's event we are delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by Lavery's lab roots is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box that appears on the
screen the speaker will answer your
questions via email if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the help desk button
located in the promotional board at the
bottom center of your screen or use the
ask a question box to let us know that
you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through July 12th 2018
you will receive an email from laberd's
letting you know when the webcast will
be available for replay please share the
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's event please
join me in welcoming dr. Watson I will
now turn the presentation over to her
thank you very much for the introduction
Judy I'm happy to get to present my work
today thank you for the opportunity
I'm speaking to you here from UC Irvine
in Southern California so we're between
LA and San Diego and I started a lab
here at UC Irvine three years ago
focused on the impact of human microbial
community colonization on human health
and as you can see in my picture of my
group here every year we paint a mural
and this one is called the phages of
Orange County because we joke that there
is more phage than housewives in Orange
County and so today I'm going to tell
you about a few of the projects in my
lab and also just give you a general
introduction to the impact of the
microbiome on health and then I just
definitely want to make sure that I
acknowledge my group members as I
mentioned I started here three years ago
and these are some of my graduate
students and undergraduate students and
also a bioinformatician with a PhD who
has have been helping with all of these
projects that I'm going to present today
so whether you're a human or a fly or
really any life-form you're colonized by
microbes the microbes got here before we
did
they've colonized the earth first 3.8
billion years and and each of us have a
unique community that stays with us for
our lives they assemble in the early
parts of our lives and actually stay
quite unique and distinct between people
if you look here I'm showing you the
hosts associated microbiota and the
density of the microbes and different
sample types so for example you'll see
that human colon samples and human
dental plaque samples are some of the
densest microbial communities on the
planet even more so than some famous
environments that you may have heard of
like soil and ocean sediments really
colon and dental plaque samples are very
densely colonized which means that we
have an enormous number of bacterial
cells which are really part of our
bodies in a way and each of those
bacterial cells are infected by another
order of magnitude worth of viruses one
of the biggest consequences of this is
that we have a huge number of bacterial
genes with very diverse metabolism that
out
our human genes by many orders of
magnitude and so what that means also is
that most of the genetic differences
between any two people are actually
encoded in our microbial communities so
you and the person sitting next to you
right now have a lot of different
metabolic capacities that are brought to
you by the microbes especially the ones
in your gut and in the last 10 years
especially since DNA sequencing has
become less expensive we've really come
to understand that disease can arise
from a disturbed microbial community so
if there are any two things that I could
ask you to remember from this
presentation they would be these two
things that first of all microbes are
found in every earth environment that
means that nothing is sterile even if
your medical textbooks are talking about
the lungs or the eyes being sterile
really nothing is sterile some things
some locations are less densely
colonized than others and certainly our
immune systems are effective at clearing
microbes out however really nothing is
sterile even you know a mile under the
Earth's surface or into the ocean you'll
still find microbes and most microbes
are not pathogens it's really a rare
minority of microbes that are able to
cause disease in another animals so most
of the microbes that I've just been
talking about are really something that
we evolved together with and they are
not causing disease another thing that I
would like you to remember are that is
that every molecule can be used by a
microbe and so that means when you take
medicines even chemotherapy drugs there
are microbes out there that can
metabolize those molecules so that has
big consequences for our diet and for
our medicines as environmental
consequences too of course so then
looking at a human microbial community
you would expect to have maybe as 10,000
different types of bacteria as I
mentioned the number of microbial
jeans greatly outnumbers the human
number of human genes and if I were to
take a middle of blood from any one
person I would find about a half a
million molecules in there and we think
that about half or so of them are
produced or modified by microbes so that
means that all of the different
molecules that are pulsing around your
body and interacting with your different
organs are affected by microbial
metabolisms another angle that I would
like to look at this from is where all
that diversity is coming from so why it
is that you're so unique from another
person and a big part of that is that
there are phages that infect viruses
phages that infect each of the bacteria
that colonize us and there are
continuous arms races between these
bacteria and the viruses that infect
them and so each time bacteria evolves
resistance to a virus it makes mutations
in order to do that and vice versa
on this phages side and so through the
years we evolved to have very diverse
and unique microbial communities part of
that is driven by the interaction
between the bacteria and the viruses
that infect them so in my lab we study
the microbial communities in a number of
ways we use DNA sequencing to capture
all of the microbial DNA out of clinical
samples and from there we can learn
about the taxonomy and the function of
the different microbes that are present
we also use different mass spec
approaches so we can use gas
chromatography and mass spec to capture
the small volatile molecules that are
present in these samples and of course
our extraction approach will have a big
impact on which molecules we catch so
you know I mentioned earlier that there
are half a million or so molecules in a
blood sample well each of these
approaches will not catch all of those
molecules but if you keep things
consistent hopefully you'll be able to
compare your samples through time
similarly we can
liquid chromatography and mass spec and
from that we capture larger more polar
molecules again depending on our
extraction conditions and so as a result
we can get a big picture of the
metabolisms that are going on and in
many cases we can understand the
microbial contribution although it's not
always easy to tell whether a molecule
has human or microbial persons and then
if we're lucky and we have an
interesting hypothesis arise out of
these data we can test the hypothesis
using in vitro culture models and just
to give an overview of what kinds of
sequencing approaches we can take we
have a number of options for how to go
about microbial sequencing so for
example we can just look at one famous
and well studied taxonomic gene the 16s
ribosomal RNA this is probably where 99%
of the data and the microbial community
field has been generated from so in that
case you take your sample store it
extract the DNA and then you amplify up
this one gene before doing the
sequencing and so that's a little
different than if you want to do full
genome sequencing where you just isolate
an individual microbe and sequence its
genome certainly it's easier to assemble
the genome that way and then finally
I've also mentioned here in yellow that
we can metagenomic sequencing where you
take the sample and you really don't do
much to it before you do the sequencing
and then you get shotgun metagenomes
which are in some ways more complex in
terms of their analysis but it's a nice
way to get a big picture of all of the
genes that are present in a particular
environment and then just a zoom in on
the 16s RNA sequencing approach because
this is how 99% of the data has been
generated in the microbiome field so
this is focusing on the bacterial 16s
ribosomal RNA which has conserved and
variable regions that are shown in green
and gray at the bottom of the slide so
the idea here is that we use PCR to
amplify the 16s gene we build primers
and the conserved green areas like where
these red arrows are and then we
amplify up that zone and compare it back
to databases and use this information to
determine the taxonomy of the microbes
present in a particular environment I
would also like to point out that my
favorite study design is longitudinal
because each person is so different from
each other if you do longitudinal
sampling then you can get samples from
the same person and look at what changes
through time and use their earlier time
points as a baseline so if you're
following for example a cystic fibrosis
patient like I'll talk about later in
the talk if you catch them when they're
feeling better you have a good baseline
for just them to compare to you if you
do a cross-sectional study it actually
becomes hard to define even what healthy
is in the first place and so it's
helpful to have longitudinal samples so
that you can compare people to
themselves okay so today I'm going to
talk about a few different projects and
and we'll be able to answer a few
different questions about them so I'll
first start talking about healthy humans
and then I'll tell you some more
specific examples from preterm infant
and cystic fibrosis patient projects ok
so here we are starting with the healthy
humans so first of all I want to give
some background on some of what we know
about bacterial diversity and got around
the world so if you look in adult
samples well actually if you look at
this plot you'll see I have age going
across the x-axis and the number of
different types of bacteria going up
across the y-axis and if you look at
adults in blue you'll notice that
Americans have less different types of
bacteria compared to people who are
sampled from Ammar India and Malawi so
if you look at age you'll see that in
the beginning of life we start out with
fewer bacteria and then starting around
somewhere between the ages of 3 & 5 the
number of bacterial types stabilizes and
it stabilizes at a lower number for
people from the United States than it
does for people from these other two
parts of the world so that in itself is
interesting
that it looks like there's less
diversity in the guts of Western people
now here's a plot summarizing an even
larger number of data from a recent
study that came out last year that was
actually focused on the Hudson
hunter-gatherers and I've simplified the
slide a little bit and I'm showing you
that here on the left-hand side of the
plot these are samples that came from
people where they are less likely to
have access to processed food whereas on
the right part of the plot you'll notice
samples that come from parts of the
world where people are very likely to
have access to processed food and the
truth is they have very little in common
so our gut microbiomes have become quite
different in the Western world compared
to parts of the world where people have
less access to processed food and at the
bottom here you can see some of the
specific microbes and their abundances
on these different populations so so
anyhow that's pretty interesting and
there's a lot to learn about how the
last hundred years of improved
sanitation and vaccination and
antibiotic exposure have affected our
microbiomes when I first started working
in this field it was about 10 years ago
and I was working in Geneva in
Switzerland and I did some projects
focused on the healthy oral microbial
communities by taking saliva samples and
so anyhow this is a picture of Geneva
this was my bike ride to work every day
and it was really early before the human
microbiome project had started and we
did some simple studies where we
collected samples from healthy people at
multiple time points so that we could
use the longitudinal approach that I
talked about earlier and some of the
first parts of the project really were
just about how to extract the DNA so
that you could grab DNA out of very
different cell types and had different
types of cell walls and then I mean our
goal was to analyze what kinds of
bacteria were present and answered
questions like how stable were the
communities inside the same person and
so here's some results from the first
project I was describing there where the
colors are
present a particular person so we have
three time points from each person and
you'll notice in this tree that the the
people cluster with themselves so that
means that that in sum this is a way of
answering the question are the
communities stable well yes in this
group of people a sample taken from the
same person looks most like another
sample taken from that same person and
it didn't matter exactly between the
time points anyhow so rural communities
remain somewhat stable inside a
particular person through time and and
then we wanted to ask questions about
whether that was true across families
and so in this project we focused on
families and we took samples 96
different saliva samples in this study
from four different families that each
had four people in them so two parents
and two children in each sample Benicia
family and so we had three days in April
three days in June and so that gave us
gave us some longitudinal information
and just to give you a sense of what was
involved in constructing the project we
collected the saliva samples we
extracted the DNA in a as unbiased a way
as possible to crack open all the tough
microbial cell types and then we used
the 16s PCR approach that I described
earlier we sequenced up those those
amplicons and then we did some quality
control to remove the bad quality
sequence data and then we used
ecological statistics to ask questions
about the alpha and beta diversity so
who is there and how different were the
samples from one another and I'll show
you some of that data so one thing that
was certainly true that pops out
immediately even just looking at the
data in a simple way is that families
share oral microbiomes and so I'm
showing you the data there's a one
sample in each of the vertical lines
here and I'm clustering them by family
so you can see which microbial taxa were
present in the different family members
clearly you can see that struct
caucus is a very abundant organism and
all of the people in this study but if
you look at the relative abundance of
some of these bacteria you can see
families one and two actually share a
lot of features as do families 3 and 4
and at the time that I did this study TM
7 and red which is quite abundant in
families 1 & 2 was actually not so well
studied and at first I was concerned
that we had a contamination issue or
something like that although there is
biology in that signal because as you
can tell it's consistently present in
families 1 & 2 and not in families 3 & 4
so if it was a contamination issue you
would expect a more widespread or random
distribution of the TM 7 which comprises
10 to 30% of the samples in some cases
so anyhow that was an interesting
discovery and it's also interesting to
think about the fact that the children
were not that distinguishable from the
adults suggesting that kids are
inheriting their microbiomes from their
parents and if their parents have a
microbiome in their oral cavity that's
associated with disease then the kids
are starting out with that starting
point so they're inheriting a
potentially unhealthy microbiome from
their parents and so there's just a lot
to learn on this front about what the
impact of the microbial community
colonization in the oral cavity is in
different families where some of them
may be changing risk for particular
diseases so just to remind you of the
strategy we did sort of doing a
multivariate analysis of the community
composition in this slide each of the
colorful lines up here represents one
piece of DNA from the 16s PCR
amplification that I described so we
take each of these different pieces we
cluster them by sequence homology where
clusters 1 2 & 3 could represent
different species of bacteria and then
as I mentioned before we look at the
samples and the different types of
clusters you know this is an abundance
matrix
it could be lions and
and bears in a different context but
here we're looking at different types of
bacteria from there we make a distance
matrix and then we use various
ordinations and projections like looking
at trees that like the one that I showed
you before to compare the samples to one
another so in one final representation
of this family data I want to show you
how how the families look compared to
one another on this random forest
multi-dimensional scaling plot
so on this plot two points that are
closer to each other have more similar
microbial community compositions and we
colored the families so that you can
tell them apart and so for example
you'll see family one in red is more
widely dispersed but it's
distinguishable from families two three
and four and in the left hand plot I'm
showing you the data at the final level
so it's if you remember your biology
Kings play chess on fine grain sand as
in kingdom phyla order and so forth
and so at the final level which is a
coarser level of detail there's less
ability to distinguish the families from
one another whereas at the genus level
which is a more fine scale level of
information you can separate the
families from one another more clearly
and if you randomly gave me a sample
from from any of the families with the
final level information I could
correctly predict which family the
sample came from eighty five percent of
the time so I would have an error
fifteen percent of the time whereas at
the genus level it would be correct
ninety percent of the time so I can tell
which family a person came from based on
the oral microbes in their saliva so
that's kind of interesting in itself too
okay my next project that I want to tell
you about comes from preterm infants and
I'll tell you a little bit about the gut
microbiome composition in creature
amendment infants at the Children's
Hospital here in Orange County
I'll also introduce you to an idea for a
phage related project although I won't
have time to go into detail with the
data so this is a study of premature
infants that was conducted with samples
collected here at the Children's
Hospital in Orange County it's a
longitudinal sample although it's
retrospective so it's not a perfectly
designed study you'll notice we have 77
fecal samples from 26 infants and they
had different health outcomes some
developed necrotizing enterocolitis some
developed sepsis and others remained
healthy although they were still being
treated with many of the interventions
that preterm infants are exposed to
including antibiotics and we used 16s
sequencing like I've described and also
gas chromatography mass spec to profile
the metabolites so here's one way of
looking at the data that we got from 16s
microbial community sequencing you'll
see we have the the infants who had
healthy outcomes although they were
stillborn preterm at the top and then we
have the infants who develop sepsis and
those who develop necrotizing
enterocolitis in the bottom panels B and
C this data has been published on the
bio archives and where the paper
actually was just accepted to M Speier
so you're welcome to look at the rest of
the data in more detail really the main
thing that I would like to show out of
this right now is that the most abundant
bacteria in all of these samples whether
the infant had a healthy outcome or
developed one of these complications the
most abundant bacteria is antara caucus
and we actually could not distinguish
the babies from these three different
groups based on the bacteria that were
present in their guts really the main
signal we're seeing is that if you're a
preterm baby and you've been given a lot
of antibiotics most preterm infants go
on a course of ampicillin and gentamicin
and so if you are a baby who's been
exposed to antibiotics like that you be
your bacteria become very enriched for
bugs like enteric caucus and
intera caucus also becomes enriched in
adults who take antibiotics so that
means that a large number of babies are
having the first months of their lives
where their immune systems are
undergoing really important development
while they're being dominated by this
bacteria and in Tara caucus now what we
didn't see very much of is
Bifidobacterium showing up here in pink
so a couple of the babies had a little
bit of bifida bacteria like number 17
here and I can't I think one of the
other babies had a little bit of digital
maybe it was number 32 oh here we are
number 22
so bifida bacteria and from what we know
in the past actually dominated infant
guts and it's an important bacteria for
digesting the energy in breast milk and
so here I'm showing you this is also
very fun to read about so I encourage
you to look into it there are bacteria
bifidobacteria that are able to access
the energy that's in found in breast
milk and in fact there's even a company
based on research that was done at UC
Davis that's now selling us the strain
as a probiotic and so we're still
learning more about it but it sounds
like around the world and in in human
history bifida bacteria was dominating
the guts of babies but that is certainly
not what happens
to preterm infants in this day and age
and actually just to motivate are
interested in Tara caucus I mean it's
actually also an important pathogen in
adults as well it can become antibiotic
resistant so you know now that we
understand we're starting to understand
the importance of the microbiome in
health you know what can we do about it
10 years ago
our main goal in our field was to
understand what a healthy microbiome
should look like and I would say that
question is still hard to answer but
we're starting to get there but let's
say we did exactly know what a perfect
microbiome should look like well how can
we get there what can we do to make that
happen so some of the options we have
for manipulating the microbiome include
taking probiotics and prebiotics so for
example eating yogurt which contains
bacteria
eating's fiber which
the group of healthy bacteria probably
the most successful example of a
microbiome research related treatment is
fecal transplants which are often used
to cure people to help treat people with
custardy difficile infections and then
another option which I think it could be
really powerful is phage therapy
the idea of using viruses that infect
bacteria as a therapy against against
bacteria so why should we care about the
viruses and the microbiome well they're
already shaping the composition and the
abundance of the bacteria that are part
of our microbiomes but they also could
be a potential therapy to treat
antibiotic resistant infections and
they've been studied in the lab and in a
few model systems like e.coli and
Pseudomonas but actually they haven't
been studied that much using the kinds
of bacteria that colonize our bodies and
as I mentioned earlier these arms races
between bacteria and the stages that
infect them are something that generate
diversity and are a big part of why each
person has such a unique microbiome
that's distinct from the person sitting
next to them this has been a big year in
the United States for reconsidering the
possibility of using phages as a
treatment for bacterial infections now
features were discovered in 1915 or 1917
depending on who you listen to you and
they they've been used as a treatment in
the former Soviet republics for example
in Tbilisi Georgia you have the le AMA
Institute where even today people
regularly use bacteria phages
to treat bacterial infections this box
here I'm showing you has a cocktail of
six stages in it but there have actually
been three cases or maybe more by now in
the United States in the last year where
the FDA has given a compassionate use
exemption and
Americans have been using phages here in
the United States as treatment for
resistant infections so this example
right here I'm showing you comes from UC
San Diego where a professor who
developed an a sonido dr. infection was
treated with the help of scientists from
San Diego and Texas and the Navy and he
actually survived his infection so his
wife is Stephanie Stephanie and she's
become a real proponent of the idea and
you know you'll see her out on Twitter
encouraging phage scientists when
there's somebody who needs a phage for a
treatment so this idea is gaining
enthusiasm but we also really need to
study how it would work and so that's
part of what has motivated some of the
projects that we've been doing in my lab
that I'm not going to go into detail
about where we are starting to study
phages that infect and pterocarpus like
the ones that showed up in our babies
and so so I'm very interested in the
possibility of using phages to treat
bacterial infections and also just to
shape the composition of the microbiome
so some conclusions from this part of
the talk include that the health of the
premature infant as in their outcome of
developing sepsis or necrotizing
enterocolitis or having a healthy
outcome is not something that really
drives the global composition of their
microbiomes and metabolites and our
paper was just published so if you're
interested in that result it's available
and then longitudinal sampling really is
critical for relating the gut microbiota
and metabolism data to health and just
that tools for shaping early life
microbiota
for example the probiotic bifida
bacteria that I mentioned and also the
phage therapy are on the horizon and so
I think these next five years are going
to be really exciting for developing
these ideas further ok the final system
that I would like to tell you about
today is about the cystic fibrosis
Airways and so cystic
is the most common inherited disorder
among Caucasians it affects about one in
3,000 people in the United States and
it's it results results from a mutation
and in an ion transport channel that
leads to thick and moveable mucus in the
airways and chronic infections so almost
like having pneumonia all the time and
patients now have a median life
expectancy of about 40 and that is
largely due to the development of a huge
diversity of antibiotics during the 20th
century and beyond and so you'll notice
that well I can tell you in the 1950s
and 60s that infants and children with
cystic fibrosis were succumbing to
infections from Staphylococcus and
streptococcus and that is really not
happening anymore and people are making
it into their 30s and 40s patients with
cystic fibrosis now have children of
their own
but of course with big consequences on
their quality of life but a big part of
that has to do with antibiotics pushing
back the staff in the strep and then now
I would say that it's a different cast
of characters in terms of the microbes
that cause trouble in the Airways of
patients with cystic fibrosis so the way
I look at the kinds of microbes that are
colonizing in the Airways of cystic
fibrosis patients is that they mainly
group into two types of populations and
so you have bugs that are sometimes
considered oral microbes so many of them
were anaerobes streptococcus as abundant
as you saw from our oral microbiota
earlier raffia camilo and so forth
and then in the lower parts of the
airways you have these long chronic
infections with very slow-growing and
antibiotic resistant bugs they're the
ones that all these decades of
antibiotic innovation have not been able
to eradicate and those include
Pseudomonas and stenotrophomonas and so
on no matter where these bugs are having
their main home base where they're
residing they are producing molecules
that are getting mixed up all the time
so if streptococcus is producing
fermentation products those can actually
get into the airways and impact disease
geology of both host cells and also the
gram negatives so that's a bit of
foreshadowing of some of the things that
I've that I've been finding here's an
example of what the communities look
like at the top I'm showing you the
taxonomy from sequencing data and at the
bottom I'm showing you the gene function
from from meta genome sequencing data
and you'll notice these characters I
just have been telling you about there's
a lot of raffia and this group of
patients and actually there's not as
much Pseudomonas but you'll see some of
the patients like this one here the
yellow patient is dominated by stain and
triple bonus which is one of these
slow-growing anaerobes gram-negative
you'll also notice the functions which
are a more constant at this level of
detail and the truth is these remain
somewhat stable for each patient and
really the holy grail and cystic
fibrosis is understanding the periods
where patient symptoms become much worse
so CF patients lives are punctuated by
periods where their symptoms become much
more difficult and they're referred to
as exacerbations they often have to go
to the hospital and receive intravenous
antibiotics in these times but it's
really hard to diagnose and the
microbial trigger is really not well
understood some some other foreshadowing
are that there's lower pH in their
sputum and breath samples and we've been
finding fermentation products from
microbial activity and that's what I'm
going to tell you about so our
hypothesis was that microbial
metabolites are good indicators of the
CF disease state because we haven't
found other ways to diagnose when a
patient is about to get worse so just
sequencing the microbes has not really
helped in the way that we were hoping
ten years ago and the sequencing first
became possible so people have somewhat
stable microbial communities when you
use the sequencing
however it's not such a new idea people
have been using breath and you
urine samples to profile the metabolites
and human samples so here's a paper from
1971 where Linus Pauling got a group of
people and he was thinking about that
microbiome at that time although we
didn't have that word and what he did
was he asked people to eat a liquid diet
with only small molecules less than a
hundred dollars in size which
essentially starved the gut microbiota
and as a result he saw that their that
their traces became more similar to each
other so patients on this simple diet
had more similar breath and urine
profiles using gas chromatography to
trace them now we know more about what
we expect to find in the human breath
sample most of it is what's in the
background air but about one percent of
the sample are these volatile organic
compounds that I'll just refer to as
breath metabolites in this study and
it's not always easy to tell if they
have human or microbial origin but these
are the molecules that we're hoping to
use to study health and it's a very
promising technique on both sides really
I collaborated with Don Breit Blake and
the Blake lab here at UC Irvine has been
studying environmental molecules and
volatiles for a long time in fact their
lab at the time led by sherry Rowland
are the ones who discovered
chlorofluorocarbons and won the Nobel
Prize in the 1990s so there are really
high precision operation and we worked
with them to collect cystic fibrosis
patient breath samples in these two
liter metal canisters one of the first
things that popped out of this data is a
microbial fermentation product called 2
3 butene dire and I'm showing you here
three samples from a sleep CF patient
and three samples from a control patient
and you'll see that there's a lot more
of this microbial fermentation product
and the CF patient so what is 2 3 butane
Diane well it's a pH neutral
fermentation product it's produced in
low pH and low oxygen conditions if you
brew beer you might have heard of it
because it's a also called diacetyl so
you can ruin the flavor of beer and
can enhance other flavors as well and
it's got really interesting toxic
properties that affect health so for
example it's the main ingredient in
microwave popcorn flavoring and you may
have heard that the people who work in
microwave popcorn facilities they have
experienced bronchiolitis obliterans and
that is the result of exposure to this
molecule which is toxic to the
epithelial cells lining the lungs so
here we are finding this molecule in the
CF patients and I'll show you a bit more
data if you look at the same patient
through time so these are days on the
x-axis and then this is the level of Qi
to be chained iron and the breath you'll
see the red samples this aren't relating
to the CF patient they're elevated in
general compared to the healthy and grey
or the room background in black except
for in this one time point and in that
time point you'll see that there's
actually not that much beauty and iron
present and the breadth of the CF
patient and that's when the patient was
taking IV antibiotics in response to an
exacerbation and so here's a signal that
we can follow that that changes with
this patient's treatment so we can't say
whether it's an increase sorry a
decrease in the production of the t3
butane diode or an increase in the
consumption but you know our hypothesis
here is that the antibiotics are
blocking the microbe that's able to
produce the t3 beating diet furthermore
this level of be chained I own is enough
to be destructive in itself and so the
red CF levels shown here are above the
dashed black line which is the safe
exposure level dictated after the
microwave popcorn factory disasters as a
safe exposure level so the molecule
could be toxic in itself we also have
been taking sputum samples and analyzing
them for molecules that are
slightly less volatile and here's an
example of a patient of a patient coming
in and this is the moment of diagnosis
of an exacerbation here at day one and
you'll see they have much higher levels
of t3 beating dial which is a product of
the same pathway just a slightly less
volatile molecules cousin and beating
Diane you'll also see an amino acid
degradation by product called Putra seen
and amino Balearic acid which is also a
protein degradation molecule so here's
some other molecules we're finding that
could be indicators of exacerbation so
I'm currently doing larger studies with
more patients to see if these kind of
signals remain true across larger
numbers of patients we also see some
correlation between these increases in
the fermentation products and amino acid
degradation products that I'm showing
here and levels of streptococcus which
is capable of fermentation whereas
Pseudomonas is not so good at that so so
it could be that we'll be able to
understand where the molecules are
coming from okay so I can see that I'm
getting low on time here I'm just gonna
go down here so we've been finding a
number of different molecules that could
be indicators of cystic fibrosis
exacerbation and each of these molecules
has a reason for having its abundance
change and so each of them can help us
get a window into what's going on in the
metabolism and the health of the patient
so I think it's interesting that we've
been able to put a GC on Mars to detect
these molecules and yet we're still kind
of in the infancy of studying the
molecules in humans I think there's a
lot of potential for using metabolomics
and other molecular detection mechanisms
for studying health in this case with
the t3 butanediol
we showed that we could detect this
molecule which tells us something about
the environment it's a pH neutral
fermentation product telling us that
the this metabolism is happening in low
oxygen conditions we also could see that
it's likely to be coming from
streptococcus and Rafi oh we did some
additional work to identify this out of
our meta genomes which you can also see
the papers that we've written about it
the molecule is directly toxic to human
cells and it can alter the physiology of
neighboring microbes such as Pseudomonas
which you can also read about in some of
our follow-up papers furthermore if you
are interested in doing metabolomics
focused work we've been working towards
understanding how the samples need to be
stored in order to be able to use them
at a below mix data so for example if
you take your samples and store them at
4 degrees C over the course of a couple
of months as we as I'm showing in this
plot you'll see that the composition of
the metabolites diverges quite quickly
within a couple of within the first day
really compared to samples that were
frozen at the -20 so getting your
samples into the freezer the day that
you collect them is pretty important for
being able to have a stable metabolomic
signature and then just one final point
that I would like to leave you with is
comparing these two contemporaries
giants and the science of microbiology
from more than a hundred years ago so
Sergey winogradsky who's famous for
developing winogradsky columns that can
study the layers of microbes and
environmental samples where you know the
top layer will be using oxygen as the
electron acceptor and the next layers
will be using the waste products from
the layer above to carry out their
respiration you know he really focused
on being able to study microbes in their
natural communities where you have a
chance to watch their interactions with
each other and with the environment and
that's just as true in the human body as
it is in any environmental sample
whereas Robert [ __ ] whose work clearly
has been instrumental in expanding the
human
span and discovering pathogens he really
focused on just isolating an individual
microbe one at a time and studying it
and this is still the basis for a lot of
the clinical microbiology that goes on
many many clinical samples are treated
the same way that Robert kok would have
suggested in order to just study one
microbe at a time and so I think in
these next 10 years we're really gonna
want to put these ideas together and
make sure that we're considering the
impact of the of the neighboring
microbes in the community on the
physiology of the pathogens that we have
been studying on purpose
okay so with that I would like to
acknowledge my my lab members and many
of my collaborators and the funding that
we've received in order to carry out
these projects and with that I'd be
happy to take digital questions and
again I'd like to thank you for the
opportunity